we are introducing this notation this
idea right this is the this is the
flipside of differentiation it's
integration it's finding areas that's
the key okay that's the idea I need to
help you understand so let's have a look
at these it's easiest to now let's step
away from the astronaut for a minute and
let's think about what we're more used
to dealing with which is you know
functions on a Cartesian plane functions
we actually know about okay so have a
look at this one with me this says and
the way I read this is the integral from
four to eight of this function with
respect to X right just like if I said
to you hey what does that mean in
comparison to say this right
this would mean how is y changing as X
changes with respect to X this is how is
y changing with respect to ah right if I
was like a horizontal axis okay so here
when you read an integral that's what
this thing is called an integral this
thing tells you what are you integrating
with respect to you just like this tells
you what are you differentiating with
respect to okay from four to eight well
I need to know what this thing looks
like right this thing here is the
equivalent of my velocity function right
so here I had this weird object here
well I'm gonna draw this this is
actually really easy to draw its from it
goes down here you'll see why in a
second I haven't drawn that part that's
what y equals X minus four looks like y
equals x minus four okay now where do
they want us to work out the area have a
look they want us to start at four and
end eight it's not exist and that's why
in fact I've only drawn the top half of
this because that spot right there is x
equals four I can ignore this and x
equals eight will be well on my graph
somewhere over there okay so I'm trying
to work out just like I did here and
this is why I shaded it to communicate
to you what was going on and you should
shade it too I want to work out what is
the area under this curve this thing
between four and eight
okay now I don't I don't think drawing
triangles sorry drawing rectangles here
makes sense because I'm always gonna
have like holes and weird things okay
but that's okay it's an area and it's
another shape that I know which is a
triangle okay so can you tell me what
the area of this triangle is what's the
UM what's the formula for the area of a
triangle 1/2 base times height 1/2 base
times height I'm thinking about that
formula rather than say where they go
this this height times width formula
because it's a different shape all right
what's the width of this or the base
rather of this triangle it's just gonna
be for right I take my floor
what's the height also for cuz the
gradient of this is just 1 so every time
you go across one unit you go up one
unit so for 1/2 times 4 times 4 1/2
times 16 is 8 that's not that hard
this thing here looks very intimidating
right the integral from 4 to 8 of X
minus 4 with respect to X but all it is
is a number okay how about this one what
is this shape what is this this is a
semicircle which kind of semicircle is
it up down left right this is a this is
a this is an OP semicircle it's the top
half right so I'm gonna enjoy it like
that
like so okay I've got a radius of I
should say a center of the origin and a
radius of 4 so that means conveniently
I've got negative 4 to 4 there right so
what is this integral asking what is the
area underneath the whole thing does
that make sense that's what this is
asking that's what integrals are
requiring from you so what's the area of
a semicircle it's 1/2 times pi times R
which is 4 squared yeah I've got 16
divided
- again that's eight but I've got a pie
sir that's eight pie make sense okay so
these objects that we're working with at
the moment they are called integrals
because we are integrating but they're a
little more specific than that you see
how I've got a value up here in a value
up here right so you start somewhere you
end somewhere you actually get a number
at the end you get a number at the end
there's a definite value to these
integrals so therefore we call these
objects where am I going to put over
here we call these objects definite
integrals because it's an integral but
you get a definite value at the end it's
not just some airy-fairy function that
can change and vary it's eight or it's
eight pi or whatever this one was a
hundred and sixty right the integral
from 1 to 3 of this function would be a
hundred 60 so it's a definite value so
we call these objects definite integrals
Eric will come to this we will come to
those in time patience young grasshopper
okay so uh one more thing one more thing
and I'm just kind of teasing this but I
can't I can't not show you the textbook
is like Oh take your time but I I'm so
excited I cannot not show you this okay
this I thought of this is an area
problem right I thought of it as an area
problem but if this is really true that
I can think of this in terms of the
primitive then let's look at this
problem again let's look at this problem
again okay I need a better space I want
to write out this thing here but using
blue clumsy using this line here okay
this all primitive idea okay so I'm
gonna say that thing the integral from 4
to 8 of X minus 4 DX equals ok I'm going
to put in this weird box thing okay so
this means whatever is in here work it
out at the end value which apparently is
8 and take that away from work here at
the start value which
is for you see where I've got those
numbers from okay
now the question is well what is the
primitive of X minus four and you know
what the primitive is right how do we
find primitives back when we were doing
this in geometrical applications of
calculus what do we do
now think carefully right because the
primitive is what happens when you undo
differentiation what did we call this
process here we called it
anti-differentiation because you're
undoing that right so the reason why we
learned antidifferentiation is because
it's at the core of integration it's
like tucked inside okay they're not the
same thing
integration is about calculating areas
but we can use a to differentiation to
find that right so what is the primitive
of this thing what do you what happens
this X you raise its power and then you
divide by that new power which is - what
about the take away 4 - 4 X now the
estate and now you will notice this is
not this is not the primitive it's just
one of the primitives right I'm going to
leave it to you to try and work out in
the next couple of days where I will
show you if you can't work it out your
own I want to let you try and work out
why do I not bother to port what's the
thing that's missing + see I don't put a
plus C there I'll let you have a think
about it if you're really sharp you'll
be able to work it out in about three
minutes okay what is he speed again
it means chucking your end value
chucking your beginning value what
happens when I put in eight I get eight
squared on to take away for lots of a
sad okay that's what happens at eight
what happens at four four squared on to
take away four watts or four is that
okay yes okay
just help me credit it on this here 64
230 to take away 32 huh
that's interesting we'll come back to
that in a second take away what what's
going on over here
sixteen on two ears sorry I should just
write eight like your tip said four
times four is
that's zero that is negative 8 which
sure enough is that now you're probably
thinking that was a lot of work I could
have just done triangle and that would
have been fine okay
that's true when the curve curve just
gives you a triangle but guess what you
don't always get nice neat triangles or
semi circles you get other things which
is really what this topic is about